thanks for joining us uh here today on
this uh lovely
or rainy afternoon
um
my name is irena from zelonz uh i work
for the holland dance festival as the
head of education and outreach
and i'm a queer white woman in my
mid-30s with long blonde hair sitting in
front of a bookshelf that doesn't belong
to me
and today i will be talking to kate
um
who i would like to invite to introduce
herself a little bit to get started
thanks irene um my name is kate i am a
um white [ __ ] woman
um
i have long brown hair with a fringe i'm
currently although you can't can't tell
i'm sitting in bed because it's the only
room i can escape my teenagers and my
dog and my cat
very happy to be here just a tiny bit
about
my
background so you know how to ask and
where you can ask
i've worked in
so-called inclusive dance for
over 20 years now i'm a
choreographer i'm a researcher
so i work as a research fellow at a
university
and i also
facilitate workshops and various
choreographic um
[Music]
residencies and all all manner of things
so my interests are i'm very interested
in um
rethinking leadership in terms of dance
and the arts and disability i'm very
interested in [ __ ] theory along with
queer theory and how these things can
empower us and give a framework to lots
of our thinking and practice
um amongst other things but i'll stop
i'll stop going on about myself but just
to give you a sense of
of where we might where the conversation
might go
i think we're exactly here to talk about
you so that was a nice start kate thank
you very much
um
one one thing that i wanted to ask you
to start off this session was exactly
that what what at this point in time
makes your heart beat faster what is the
thing that gets you the most excited in
this particular moment so we know you
have this long history of
uh researching and working in the field
but
today what makes you the most excited
in your field that's a great question um
i think i've become really hooked on
research
in the last few years i've become really
um
i enjoy so much
uh thinking about through my practice
and through other outputs maybe written
or maybe speaking to other people
of really grounding what what we do as a
sector and what we think in into
research terms so that's become very
important for me and and i feel
passionate about that because
um [ __ ] or disabled researchers are in a
real minority in dance and arts research
and i i'm really passionate about
growing that so that's the first thing
and then the second thing which is
perhaps a bit more emotional
i currently feel so um
what really fires me up actually i'm
gonna age myself now i get really fired
up by um the generation behind me
so when i encounter younger hungrier
less apologetic
brilliant [ __ ] and disabled artists who
are actually
um uh they're they're
not less polite because they are polite
but i feel like they're there is
something in that they're they're less
yeah they're less polite maybe in what
they're demanding and i find that really
exciting it's really invigorating
to be around um and to be part of and to
to also get a sense of um what the
future might be and actually how the
work that we those of us who've worked
in this way for a long time how that
work has fed into younger generations
i'm just so excited to see how they
practice differently and they answer ask
different questions
that's that really fires me up
nice very exciting yes in the in the
video that we sent along with this uh
invitation you briefly spoke about that
as well so i had made some of my notes
and i was thinking that is so exciting
this this idea of this this
newer younger generation being
completely unapologetic about their
place
in the field in the field of dance in
gender identity in in climate change in
many things but here let's let's stick
to the
the dance element of it but
uh and i completely agree that that is
very exciting development what do you
think we can learn from that
from that attitude how can we maybe use
that to our advantage or
what about that inspires you to
um maybe change also the way you think
about the way you work
i i think that oh that's another great
question i think
um
on a real this is perhaps a strange
answer but on a really practical answer
i learned i learned so much from from um
upcoming generations of [ __ ] artists
around actually around language and it's
you you'll maybe note that i'm really um
it's been quite recent for me to lean
into identifying as a [ __ ] person a
quick researcher because of my my
i span a generation where that wasn't it
required such a lot of explanation and
i'm really learning from the language
that people are using to describe
themselves to describe their work and
it's interesting that you you talked
about this excitement that also relates
to um i think you said gender identity
and climate change because actually for
me they go they they're really aligned
so i often find that these really
exciting [ __ ] artists are also engaging
so and i think that's what that's been a
really important learning thing for me
that we don't have to make work or be
involved in settings that are specific
or tokenistically around disability we
can actually um
speak we can we can exercise our here's
a mouthful exercise our expertise in
other areas as [ __ ] artists we can make
and that that's exciting to me that i
see many many [ __ ] artists making work
that's just about their knowledge of the
body or the world or commenting on
something else and i think that's been a
definite shift
um
yeah and also i think
i come from a generation i feel
where
as [ __ ] artists or disabled artists
there was an expectation to conform so
for me lots of the labor of my work has
been trying to
um
not erase my disability but actually to
to be in the mainstream this was a
really repetitive thing
when you when you're in the mainstream
when people don't notice then you kind
of made it
and i'm really excited by and i'm
learning from from
younger artists this idea of
it's a slight rejection of the
mainstream actually a a less
borrowing from a from a
narrative or a language that already
exists but really creating
a new language that suits us and i think
you know i feel really privileged to be
around that and to learn from that and i
i'm feeding it in all the time to my
practice and my writing
nice
very exciting and i see you nodding a
lot my lucy is there any if there's any
moment where you want to ask a question
please don't hesitate to unmute wave
lisa i don't know if you're there if you
can hear us but the same goes for you of
course
um so please don't hesitate to either
type in the chat as joe said or uh raise
your hand or unmute because we're not
that many so
yeah i'm actually interested in this
this idea of the the intergenerational
stuff i think
um in my work with disability alternate
we work with a lot of
um what i would call kind of
uh stalwarts of the disability arts
movement who were there
part of
direct action network and they're in the
70s and 80s and
all that sort of stuff so they're like
probably i guess a generation before uk
at least um
and
then
and
and then they
they're
maybe there's like this it's kind of
changed it say it's gone from that came
from the sort of agit prop very
politicized
um way of making art and then maybe it's
changed and maybe hopefully it's going
back again
and but it also seems like the
the understandings of disability itself
are quite different between the
generations and i sort of think
it's also really important to
for for that intergenerational learning
i guess for kind of learning from from
the people who
who were there decades ago fight
fighting for rights and stuff and and uh
and as well learning from the younger
generation from that sort of
youthful fight exuberance and fire in
the belly but
was also like um
this idea of not reinventing the wheel
sometimes as well and that like past
work has
has you know past
work has been done and
and there's there's stuff to learn from
that as well anyway yeah i'm rambling
now no no but well at least i i feel
what you're saying it's really nice to
know whose shoulders you're standing on
and who got you to where you are but
also to at the same time
um
not necessarily conforming to that
as the the newer generation that
supports you and that gives you a base
and it gives you roots maybe that gives
you
a place where you come from but that
doesn't necessarily define where you
have to go so i i i totally agree it's
very interesting to see
the previous generation but to get this
excitement from the newer generation is
also fascinating i also it's melissa i
can see you've got your hands up so i'll
make this a really quick one that i just
just in response joe to your and this is
going to be a bit um
cynical of me not cynical realistic of
me i i think i think you're right that
we that if we think back to our
uh cultural or historic legacy around
disability activism
we you know we have that but we have
that to build on that strong foundation
and i think we have had a period of not
really connecting to that and i do think
we're back to
a deeply politicized way of being and i
don't think that necessarily means being
politicized as in
um it doesn't have to be
just politicized around disability i
think it's more complicated than that
and i the cynical i don't know if it's
cynical this is going to sound negative
but i think it's important i actually
think that that's been forced by um
huge seismic economic societal shifts
that have actually
thrown disabled people back into extreme
precarity and i think that's what that's
what is is happening
to some extent that that initial
activism came from a place of really
having um
limited rights
a real inequality and i think and it's a
depressing comment but i think we're
certainly in the uk we're shifting back
to that
definitely through through the pandemic
you know i've seen disabled people and
disabled artists that i know have been
made hugely precarious by governmental
decisions i think that's forced a moment
to go hang on a minute this we can't
we're not having this and it it it's
almost like coming from a a place of um
having to rather than choosing to so i
think it's a great comment mainly sorry
i overtook so you've got your hand up
yeah
go ahead
hi everyone
i'm really happy to be here and listen
to you kate and it's been a long time
since
like i heard from your work and i've
listened to
a lot of videos and interviews and i'm
really interested in
what you do and your experience
um i'm also a disabled artist i'm based
in the french basque country so south
west of france
and
you know i'm in this generation also
that is a little bit in the middle
between your generation
and the new generation
generation z
um
and i also think that there is this
shift going on right now but my question
is because i live in france and maybe
disability is not the same like we don't
talk about disability the same way in
france and in the uk
um and as a disabled artist i'm really
struggling sometimes to
talk about my work and talk about what i
do
in a radical way or political way
because
france is very politically correct
country
and
and when you talk about disability it's
about the social aspect of it
and when you're doing culture
you're in the culture there is no
funding for inclusive dance like as a
cultural
um
genre or style
so it's quite
it's not really a question but it's a
common and like is the new world and the
world and institutions are really ready
for artists
like me who are disabled and
want to do things differently are they
really ready for us to
come and
how could we make them ready
you know how can we
how can we push for our needs to be
considered
i don't know do you have an opinion on
that yeah i think that's a really great
observation
and i i think the first thing that that
interests me about what you're saying is
how um
often
when we have really cemented cultural or
social understandings of disability
however well-meant they are
they can actually really make us
invisible they make
make it very difficult to have
fluid or radical conversations because
we are we become as disabled people
trapped in a language that doesn't come
from us
we become trapped in an in an
understanding of disability that is put
on us rather than one that we choose
because speaking for me permanent
permanently personally and probably
permanently
i don't have a fixed sense of my my
disability i do have my fixed sense of
my identity as a quick person as a
disabled person but within that it
changes all the time
so if someone were to layer on me or you
need this today or you need that today
and it's actually really unhelpful in
kind of progressing
and and moving things forward and i
really understand the different
geographic context it's interesting i
was having a um
uh interesting for this zoom
particularly because i had a
conversation with a friend of mine who's
not a dancer but who is a fluent french
speaker and lived in holland for many
years and she was talking about the
understanding of disability and her work
is around um
working with migrant cultures and and um
she just said that she said exactly what
you've said may list that in france it's
kind of bound up in a way that is very
difficult to penetrate to have any kind
of truly progressive conversation um so
just to say that someone else said the
exact same thing as you
what what i don't know what the answer
is what excites me at the moment and
it's been a strange
twist of um
of um
kovid is that i think um
uh
we are so more connected
we can collectivize as disabled people
now across countries across contexts and
i really i'm already feeling the power
in that because i think we we've all
felt um connected to each other but we
can actually now come into these virtual
spaces and we can we can feel supported
by one another we have an allyship
between us rather than an allyship that
depends on non-disabled
uh gatekeepers frankly around us so
and i really hope that you and lots of
many other disabled artists can draw on
that and go eve even to go ah this thing
happened and i'm frustrated or i need i
i don't know i want to use this language
i want to
you know even practical things like
writing about articulating your practice
and then putting that out to your
networks your peers to your quick
friends and going
what what are you reading from this
language what does it mean what can i
change and i think we need to capitalize
on that more and really lean into each
other so i know that's not an answer and
i just want to say i really hear how
frustrating it must be
to be in that in that context and i
think
one of one of the things that i you'll
you'll all know dan dore
i'm sure um or dan's practice so dan's a
really good friend of mine and we just
worked together on his solo show a bit
um and we talk a lot about the impact of
being or feeling like the only one and i
think we've probably all felt like that
at different points in our lives and our
careers
and that's hard it's really hard to feel
like you're kind of flying a flag on
your own and i just i'm really um
excited about how we can find a way to
connect with each other so nobody has
that feeling that they're on their own
but yeah great comment joe you've put
something in the chat but you've also
put your hand up so yeah i mean the
thing in the chat i've encouraged oh
yeah time if you want to take a look at
it it was a great event last night just
real sense of community and and
kind of rediscovering that feeling of
what it was like at the beginning of
lockdown when everyone was kind of it
felt a bit like we're all in it together
and it doesn't feel like that anymore
and it it just felt like that
feeling again a little bit anyway and it
sounds
some of the similar themes was that
gareth and gemini yeah yeah so just what
a tiny world we live in gareth and i i
feel very proud of gareth and gemma
because
um i did an event uh pro program with
the arts council called change makers
where we bought together
21 um queer [ __ ] artists of color to
come together and in the hope that they
would collaborate so i brought them
together i mentioned
i feel like they're my babies yeah well
if you haven't seen the event was
absolutely brilliant i'm gonna catch up
with it
they're super exciting i love them no it
was really good but i i wondered about
um the thing i wanted to ask you about
actually was i sort of in the rush to
reopen um and all those kind of things
when we still got so many you know
members of our community are shielding
and
like whether like how we navigate that
as artists and whether that's
conversations we should be having with
venues when when venues are looking to
program us and yeah i just that the real
sense of sort of of disabled audiences a
little bit and certainly performance as
well but of that
getting left behind in the in in the in
the rush to
go back to normal or whatever it is and
whether there's a role as as artists and
performers
to be having those conversations with
venues if they're kind of not making
that provision that they that they
magically managed to make
yeah
i was i was involved in two two projects
over lockdown both of which i'm
immensely proud of
the first one is actually two because
we've done a second one now was a
edited collection called in other words
which was um
a book of uh writing musings artworks by
again queer [ __ ] and artists of color
and the first book was around exactly
what you're saying joe it was about
what does it feel to be hurtling towards
a new normal when normal didn't ever
mean anything to you in the first place
and it's beautiful because it's full of
fear it's full of hope it's full of
anger and the second book asks okay
now we're in that new normal allegedly
how are you now and so it's for me and i
that's why i think that's in part
comment to your question
your comment even that that's something
we can do we can we can when we have the
facilities because i i did this with
some funding and with an arts
organization called metal
and we were able to create a space for
those feet to bring people together in
those um
with with their experiences and the
other slightly drier but equally
important project i did was an arts
council-funded project
um
called the
dc-4cc disabled consultants for creative
change
and it was me and three other disabled
producers
having various conversations with
disabled people primarily about audience
and
audience and artists and what what was
very what really came home to me is when
we asked the question of what do you
want as we
emerge was please don't change
streaming please keep things online
please don't marginalize
us for needing to be virtual please
don't punish us in whatever way for
needing to shield
i'm not sure that that's but that was
the that was
loud and clear from everybody
but i think joe your concerns are right
that i'm not sure
venues in the the capitalist model of
wanting to get back to money and and
um filling auditoriums i'm not sure
they're thinking about that
so i i guess the the pr the pragmatist
in me
says one one solution to that is let's
get really really clear on articulating
that so you know and literally like in
policies in
in the riders that we put through as
performers and in what we what what we
demand as audience members and there is
some really interesting stuff happening
and i think we've really got to um
amplify that because i think the
conversations are there like dan dore is
having them i know claire cunningham you
know all these brilliant artists that we
all know they are pushing for that and i
think we've got to amplify it to the
point where it becomes very difficult
for venues to not stream their work and
finally sorry i'm rambling because that
is i am very passionate about this and
also to
nod to the venues that do do it like
actually i'm working on and off with the
junction in cambridge
and they're brilliant
they're absolutely committed to
continuing to stream and they're really
committed to thinking about how they
invite disabled audience members into
their venue and how they work with
disabled artists so it's really good to
kind of not wait where you see it to go
there that's good practice
absolutely yeah i wonder if something
like
shared tools or
or if there's you know as well as this
research which demonstrates
those kind of things of how excluded
people
yeah and how left behind people are
feeling it in in the way if there's a
central thing that that like you say
that you could include in artists
writers that we could circulate yeah and
i i also think that sometimes and
including myself hugely in this
sometimes we don't know what we need and
so i had a really great conversation
with um
i'm gonna mispronounce their name i mean
you probably know them sin i made this
youtube syndrome
yeah
so syndrome was we had a really great
conversation and they said
i don't yeah said exactly what i said i
don't know what i need from from monday
to friday it might change so what i
actually need from a venue is to
understand that that's a changeable
thing
and i think that's the same as audience
members to not assume that everybody
just needs access that we might need
access that means we can come in and out
of a theater we might need access that
means we can arrive 10 minutes late
because actually we don't want to be
there at the beginning or we can sneak
out five minutes early or
all those things but i think you're
right i think some kind of um toolkit or
documentation that articulates that for
us
um
would be really good
because to be clear i don't think it
that should fall on artists
at all it's it's the responsibility of
venues but yeah it's just you you know
you do get the opportunity sometimes to
have a dialogue with a venue yeah um
and it's worth taking that opportunity
isn't it if you're able to but but again
i think it's an extra labor to fall on
i think for for me that that links in a
little bit also with something that um
that you said at the end of the video
that we shared with everyone
about asking people for advice and help
and i'm thinking about the situation in
france i live in in france as well
um so
that is really
a humongous difference between the
situation in france and the situation in
the uk so
thinking about that like
you're advising younger artists or maybe
artists in different countries that
don't have the same access to
experienced artists to ask this advice
from you and others from
the others that you mentioned for
example claire and dan and people with
more experience maybe
what would you say oh yeah go no go you
go you finish your question you know i
wasn't saying what would be some of
those experiences that were crucial for
you that you think
that you want to share like if the
person is not necessarily coming to you
and saying okay what do you think about
this but what are the things that you
feel
that are worth really worth sharing in
terms of experience if you look for
example to the french context where
they have
so so much work to do like it's
it feels daunting it feels really scary
to to look at that country and and see
how little there is and how far
it still has to has to come
yeah
i think i mean that's a huge question i
think
that
where have i i actually think i've done
most of my profound learning in much
smaller contexts actually when i haven't
been trying to break down a big wall or
when i haven't when i've the i've done
most of my
my really kind of yeah active learning
when i've been like with just my
collaborator welly in the in the studio
or when i'm working with the filmmaker i
work with and we're just in that process
of
where i'm that that's where i think i'm
really
learning and i don't know how and the
reason why that's complicated for me is
because i'm really aware i perhaps
couldn't have learned that when i was 20
that i was i i prac you can't it's very
difficult to imagine myself going back
and
saying to my 20 year old self oh don't
be in the mainstream be radical do your
own thing because i was in i was in a
different place and everything was
different so now but i do i think
there's um
yeah i don't know i don't know how to
make i'm trying to find a moment where
i've really where that i would want
people to know and i think i just would
want i would want to say to um
to all disabled people who are in
difficult geographic context or whatever
difficult context is
um yet to lean into or just be around
the communities that are
we're so
we're so closely knit as a community
across countries i think as well i had
um
an
interesting meeting with colleagues in
poland following up from the polish lab
um that i did in october
and
someone that someone from the british
council brilliantly said well what would
you like what would you like next and
they all said oh uh maybe to have kate
back but also canduco and also stopgap
and maybe claire cunningham and
i kind of found myself and i'd never
really thought about it before i was
like actually
what i and i know this is radical and it
completely kind of resists capitalism in
a way
it's just where is there a space where
we can tap into the fact that we all
know each other
so actually if you get me
you've got access to claire if you get
claire claire is a phone call or an
email away from saying okay i've had
this question what do you think about
this same with maylis that there's this
we have this communication that that
we don't have to go stop gap do this and
that because we all the truth is we all
know each other so actually
we can share information really freely
um and point point each other in you
know there's enough to go round i think
is what i'm saying
um
that we don't with and that feels really
important oh sorry i'm going off on
attention but yeah
but that seems like very solid uh advice
also like maybe not to be afraid to
reach out to people that maybe they're
in another country or maybe you've only
met them once but
exactly as you said the the network is
so
tightly knit that that
you can find your way in and and
maybe that maybe that touched me that
you said that like ask
us for advice
but and also to to um to kind of get
political
you know
we the disabled the [ __ ] community we
are oppressed we're historically
repressed sorry that's a freudian slip
i'm not repressed honestly
we are oppressed and we're historically
oppressed and we are oppressed now and
we're looking at a future of oppression
and that that's that's the existence and
i'm not saying that's all we experience
the reason why i'm making that comment
is if you're asking an oppressed person
who is who is you know because actually
and i'm sorry melissa i'm sorry i mean
because this may not resonate with you i
don't know joe if it's the case for you
yeah i'm a [ __ ] artist i'm all those
things but i've also gone through
arduous
long processes of securing any kind of
benefit relating to my disability that
is a part of my experience so i know how
that feels i know about objectification
that you know i'm not i'm not just kind
of oh it's all about inclusive dance all
those other things
that i regularly get
objectified or marginalized on my way
into go and speak at a conference or to
do a performance that might be by a taxi
driver or someone on a train or that
happens to me all the time so if an if a
another disabled person reaches out to
me of course i'm going to want to
connect with them because we
automatically share something not
everything but we share this line and
i'm really excited by that line and i
don't think we make enough of it that we
share we there's i wrote something
recently and i'm well i'm not being i am
bigging myself up because i i thought it
was such an important thing to say
we don't automatically understand each
other's experiences but we can go i know
something about where you're at maybe
not exactly maybe but i know a little
bit of where you're at and that's got to
be a really good starting point for a
conversation
absolutely
it's really beautiful
um
i had another question actually yeah
totally unrelated
i was just trying to think as well about
the kind of people who might be watching
this back and i know that
um
i know that there's in the or certainly
within europe beyond access there's a
lot of artists to
um you know their primary experiences as
as performers
um
and i know that for people who their
primary experiences as a performer
moving into being the creative
moving into being the creative force
is like a really hard transition for
people to make
and i wondered if you had any advice on
kind of
on that on how you can develop your own
language your own voice like how how
you've done that with what you what you
would kind of characterize that has for
you i know that's i know it's a
difficult one
voice how you go from
from kind of
realizing someone else's great vision to
kind of developing your own
[Music]
that's no that's just such an important
question and i i the reason i think it's
important is i think that is a
transition that so many performers make
but i'll talk about it particularly as a
dancer that you know it was no secret i
was in canduco for five five years and
the way that canduco works is
you're
you are
um
a dancer a tool for someone
primarily a non-disabled vision
so
which is i'm making
no comment around that but that's that's
the reality of that situation you you i
was a dancer for some somebody else's
idea of what they wanted to say about
disability
and then to transition into so it's a
slow a kind of accidental transition
into
starting to make work with welly who's
willie o'brien who some of you may or
may not know
um who's my long-term friend and
collaborator and that was a very easy
transition because it was just the two
of us we were tr we'd both been in
canduco we were both going right what do
we want to say and sometimes we got that
wrong
and sometimes we
uh weren't articulate and it would be
different if we did it now but that was
so that was a gentle transition
and then i just i think i actually think
it was it was getting into research that
really that that's where i found my
voice and my language and actually i
found it
by by
resisting normative language by by
really getting to a point of going that
language doesn't work for me that
codified way of working in dance or
speaking about disabled bodies crit
bodies on stage in studios it doesn't
fit my body so i started to play around
with this this kind of messy language
and actually so much of my practice is
about mess
but but in a really um
unapologetic way that i you know i
really want to welcome that mess i
really want to welcome playing with
what my practice might be what my
language is
um
and i think i've said this in the film
that you've seen i i am
not always
physically in life i do feel really
supported i feel part of a very powerful
network is small but i feel part of a
network of disabled artists disabled
researchers who i just feel like they've
got me
and actually that gives me the the um
ability the um
confidence to kind of speak speak from
and and sorry joe this is probably much
more than you wanted in my experience
that's what people want to hear actually
even in the most
high brow academic conference what
people actually want to hear is for you
to speak from experience and truthfully
um and that doesn't always land well
but i'm quite stubborn about not
changing that i'm quite stubborn about
this is how i speak this is what you're
gonna get from me
um
i'm not gonna sit and read from a piece
of paper about
foucault although i do that sometimes
occasionally but not very well um
yeah i because i think that's more
useful
oh thank you for that
uh i'm seeing that lisa you've joined
yeah nice to see you
yes nice to see you um
is there anything that you would like to
share or ask kate at this point
um okay
thank you
um okay thank you what you just said
then
really helps me because i i have been
doing ensemble work since i started
working in the arts and i'm just about
in the middle of this year or later on
this year i'm going to start my first
residency to create my own work in
australia
and i must admit to being
really really scared
um up until this point
and then hearing you say that it's like
yeah you know finally
i don't have to
do say
move
in in somebody else's curated way and
you're saying you know
you make it messy i'm going oh it's like
a little bit of freedom
i can i can be a hot mess
from my first
and my personally
because i'm just i'm just figuring it
all out really what i what i want to say
i mean i've got it all in my head this
this idea this this story this this
vision that i've had it's probably been
in my head for the past
five to eight years and finally i get a
chance to do it so hearing you say what
you just said
i i'm feeling so much more confident
that
yeah this is going to be a cracker of
the show yeah thank you i just no thank
you and i just i want to say lisa that
can you see maylis on screen
so did you say did you see me this also
at the time you were talking like
dancing like yes yes that's that's what
i'm talking about it's crit power right
there that you're not on your own
and yeah yeah
yeah
yes that is that's good and
and i you know i'm really want to be
transparent about that genuinely i
my position is drop me an email drop me
a facebook message anything if you want
because if i if you are doing if you're
in the studio and you create 10 minutes
of work and you want an eye on it
even if i can't do it i know there is
someone else who will do it and who will
want to do it and i think that's a
really important thing that we that we
all tap into
that's really where about australia are
you or will you be
uh i will be in
melbourne victoria so yeah i'm currently
in um bremen germany at the moment okay
so yeah so so will you be able to access
the brilliant caroline bowditch when
you're in melbourne yes i i will and do
you know carolyn do you know caroline
already
yeah she used to be my boss
oh
i bet she's a formidable boss i'm not
sure i'd want casual to be my boss
yeah it's pretty formidable but yeah
there's a really good [ __ ] community in
this in melbourne so um
yeah i have every confidence that i've
you know got got a lot of people being
able to pass the critical eye but it's
so important that we get to look at each
other's work and say hey yeah great or
have you thought of doing it this way or
yeah i want to say
and you know what else i'm a big
believer in that when we
it's also fine to share work with people
who who you know will get it and just go
can you just say nice things about this
i'm just sending this to you to look at
you and and to be really clear i want
you to look at this and give me a
critical eye or just i want you to look
at this because i need to share it with
somebody
i'm not i'm not looking for feedback
that's something i've learned really
late in life that is okay to ask for
people to look at something without a
critical feedback both are good but
really yeah well okay that's very
encouraging because sometimes it's just
good to put your work out there and just
know that it's being seen but you know
it's good to just go this is what i want
you to this is how i want you to comment
and i've actually really learned that
from doing phd supervision that when
someone sends you they're really hard
sweated over 10 000 words
it's really good for them to say go
through this with a fine tooth comb or
be gentle and just go you know because
sometimes people don't want grammar
checked because they're not at that
point yet or they don't want a really
critical eye so you can read things it's
important to be able to read things
differently i think
wow
i'm feeling so positive now thank you
yeah
i was gonna say yeah i'm gonna
sort of slowly bring this to a close my
list if you have a last question maybe
for kate
um
yeah yes i would like to
um ask kate something around leadership
because um it was a part of um the video
too and i was very interested in that
um i'm the artistic director of a
collective project and we've been
selected in perform europe i don't know
if you heard of it yeah brilliant um
and we are
going on tour next week we are going to
denmark sweden france we are like
traveling triangle
for 10 days we are very excited but
it's been a journey like it's been
really really tough
um
i found three incredible partners
programmers in denmark sweden france
who were really really helpful but it's
been a lot of work a lot of admin a lot
of emails
a lot of
production work
that
um
it really put me into almost burnout
last week like i was completely
overwhelmed by anxiety and everything
and then i'm i'm currently like i'm an
anxious person like
on my daily basis it is a part of who i
am i try to embrace it as an artist and
be who i am
but we are facing the fact that being a
leader and being anxious and being
artistic director and being
that
well i questioned myself in terms of the
like
did i choose the right career did i
choose the right path because i'm so
anxious and it's hard to be
that anxious and being a leader of a
project and i was currently asking
myself a question like can we start a
conversation around
being a leader
and being anxious or having mental
health problems because
it's a reality i know a lot of disabled
people who deal with anxiety on a daily
basis and i'm like where are they and
can we talk about this because i feel
very lonely when i'm in this situation
and i'm like
how can we bring the
anxiety and depression and
all of this can impact our
ability to
products
send emails being like
on time and being like super and i'm
like
can we talk about this and where like
it's part of leadership but it's like
how can we be leaders if we have to
do exactly the same thing as
non-disabled people yes exactly we don't
have the same lives of non-disabled
people you know that yeah yeah i mean
can i comment have i got time to do that
yes of course this feels so important
that
firstly you're already doing it you've
done it you've but you've got a 10 week
talk you've got a 10-day tour you're
doing it so you that's the first thing
the second thing is absolutely i feel
really passionately that um so
sorry to be that annoying person who
references their own bloody phd but
one thing that i did in my phd which i
must credit to my supervisor because it
was her suggestion is i created a
taxonomy of leadership which was around
gentle leadership um and actually i'd
love to bring anxious leadership into
that that how do we rethink so we're not
butting up against leadership is because
it's it's alarming
how even in the arts we are dominated by
a model of leadership that is from the
top kind of doing everything survival of
the fittest and it's so jarring with the
experience with a [ __ ] experience or a
disabled experience
that yes of course what we need to do is
um
is is really owned those things of being
i mean i'm an i'm anxious and anxiety
feeds into my leadership i rarely ever
go into something going it's definitely
this but i've learned to embrace that's
my leadership style i like to have other
people around me i like to
make decisions through conversation and
discussion
um
i also on a practical note and i know
this is not always viable because of
support that's a lot to be an artistic
director and a producer and do all the
administrative work that's an awful lot
i know sometimes it's inevitable so i
just i think you need to kind of
just acknowledge that for yourself
that's like three jobs
it's three leadership jobs because the
majority not the majority many artistic
directors can just hand that stuff over
so you're already doing a lot
on a practical thing and i know you'll
all know them
i really love the way that jess tom
tourette's hero
talked do you do you know jess
and jess is really open about sharing
their practice and i i i love the way
when your work i've just worked with
jessica's um just contributed to the
second book that i did
and actually
real clarity in we we acknowledge we
work within qrik time so we don't pick
up we don't always pick up emails
between nine to five this is the way we
work we often we might cancel last
minute because of the needs of the
people that we work with
there's something that i think must be
such a relief and i'm getting better at
doing that i'm not perfect at it but i
think there's some learning for us to do
there to say this is what i can do and
this is where my boundary is this is
where i will not respond to an email or
actually don't i don't want to be in a
whatsapp group because it's overwhelming
or
or these are these are my working days
or my rehearsal times
and that's that takes bravery because
we're pushing against a very traditional
system
um
but it feels
really important and i just think
and this is this is again sorry to be
cynical i think if we don't do that
we're setting ourselves up to fail
because if you look
and joe may know more than this than i
do but if you look at the history of in
the arts of disabled people in
non-disability-led organizations
undertaking leadership positions they're
often very short-lived and the reason
for that i think is because that person
is exhausting themselves trying to fit
into
a normative way a pace and time of
understanding work
so until we can start to say no no this
is what leadership look like looks like
for me we're consistently going to be
because because politics and political
correctness is telling organizations
they have to employ disabled people
which of course they do
sometimes but if they don't put in place
an acknowledgement of quip time that
disabled person is just being set up to
fail
and i that for me that has to change and
i'm seeing it in jess's work i see it in
dan's work there's some amazing artists
that i could name and i'm sure joe knows
loads more of people who are actually
saying this is you know and actually
it's quick time it is and that's such a
such an amazing
um
philosophy for one of a better word that
i think we can all
um
learn from and work with them
yeah our organization we do um
co-leadership as well so like we have
co-chairs instead of having one chair of
the board we have we have our own
disabled and disabled uh co-chairs
um
and i
uh yeah co-leadership
uh models can be really helpful i think
i you know it's it's quite an
established practice generally in the
arts that you have like an artistic
leader and a like a chief executive role
who's who's more on the kind of
practical side of things
um
so there's lots more examples like that
but there's kind of co-leadership i'll
also think can be uh can be really
helpful in that way because you kind of
cover each other's bases in terms of way
you know way way where you struggle and
where the other person excels
um it's impossible for one person to
have
all of the attributes that are needed
sometimes
and those things
yeah a great 100
thank you
so much thank you kate for sharing all
these very insightful
things and uh don't stop quoting your
own phd i find it incredibly fascinating
so
please continue quoting it
thank you so much uh lisa and my name is
for for being here with us today for
joining us thank you joe for
organizing all this the logistical side
of things and our two hidden
ah modena thanks for setting it up
for getting us all together and thanks
for captioning um we'll use that also in
the recorded version probably
yeah
thanks irene for holding us
it was my absolute pleasure so thank you
all very much for being here and
i hope you walk away or roll away
inspired
from this conversation
you